la joélette est prête pour accueillir
lice 40 ans atteint d'arthrogrypose une
maladie congénitale
elle se manifeste par des raideurs au
niveau de différentes articulations
c'est une maladie qui paralyse donc les
articulations pendant le développement
des foetus et en fait ça a restreint le
développement musculaire et articulaire
on a des limitations différentes selon
selon les personnes pour cette cinquième
édition les marcassins du coeur
organisent cette course solidaire en son
honneur en départ du siège sodexo de
guyancourt
il existe trois parcours le parcours de
marche le parcours de course à pied de 8
km c'est notre course que nous allons
faire aujourd'hui d'ailleurs et les
parcours de trail un 10 km avant de
débuter la course un échauffement
s'impos certains participants étaient
déguisés les frais d'inscription d'un
montant de 15 euros sont reversés à
trois associations
on a une récurrente ces des restos du
coeur les restos du coeur des
clayes-sous-bois c'est notre partenaire
depuis là depuis le début de la première
édition
ensuite on effectivement on choisit deux
autres associations qui n'ont pas
forcément pignon sur rue qu'on ne
connaît pas forcément là c'est l'argent
pays comtois et la tarentaise népal
ceinture bouclée lise maman de trois
enfants est prête pour un parcours de 8
km à bord de sages aux ailettes en
fauteuil tout terrain 270 participants
munis de leurs dossards se sont
mobilisés par le fait que ce soit ça
soit pour une oeuvre caritative me suis
dit je paye beaucoup de courses donc
j'aime bien aussi payer des courses ou
où l'argent va quelque part dit il en
attendant le retour des coureurs 40
bénévoles dont alain s'occupe de
l'approvisionnement grâce aux dons de
nos fournisseurs et partenaires donc
nous avons plus d'une dizaine de
fournisseurs qui chaque année nous
propose des produits
les participants ont pu se ravitailler
après la course elle s'est déroulée
pendant leur pause déjeuner pour sa
première participation ce coureur a
effectué 8 km sur l'a8 est avec nous
c'est génial un peu un peu glissant un
peu mouillé sur le deuxième lac sur une
partie du parcours
je fais très attention de ne pas glisser
avec cette cinquième édition les
marcassins du coeur ont reversé près de
4000 euros aux associations